Now let's look at how the principles
of authentication and
key exchange that we have discussed
are used in actual systems.
Kerberos is a standard protocol
used to provide authentication and
access control in a network environment,
typically an enterprise network.
Every entity in a network,
that is, all users and
network resources,
such as workstations and
printers, have a master key that it
shares with the Kerberos servers.
And the Kerberos servers perform both
authentication and key distribution.
So for convenience, we use KDC
to refer to a Kerberos server.
For a human user, the master key is
derived from his or her password.
For a network device,
the key is configured in.
All the keys are stored
securely at the KDC.
Now let's go over a few
typical Kerberos scenarios.
When user Bob logs in,
his workstation contacts the KDC with an
authentication service request message.
The KDC generates a per day session key,
SB.
And the so-called ticket-granting ticket
that contains SB and the ID of Bob.
And the ticket is encrypted
using the KDC's own key.
The KDC then sends back a message
to Bob's workstation, and
this message is the authentication
service response.
The message contains the per day session
key and the ticket-granting ticket.
And the message is encrypted using the
shared master key between Bob and KDC.
And because KB is the master
key shared between Bob and
KDC, only Bob's local workstation
can decrypt this message.
And then it can store the private
key and the ticket granting ticket.
Bob's local workstation will then use SB
for subsequent messages with the KDC,
and it would include the ticket
granting ticket to remind and
convince the KDC to use SB.
That is, any new request to the KDC will
include the TGT in the request message.
And the new ticket from the KDC
will be encrypted using SB.
There are several benefits
with this scheme.
First, the localhost does not
need to store Bob's password or
password hash once Bob has logged in and
once he has obtained SB from the KDC.
Second, the master key KB,
that Bob shares with the KDC,
is only used once everyday
when Bob logs in initially.
That is, the exposure of the master key,
which is derived from Bob's password and
is subject to password guessing
attacks is very limited.